- [Voiceover] A pair of jeans
that regularly costs $40
is on sale for 30 percent off.
As part of a promotion, each
customer will also receive
an additional discount
on the marked sale price
at the cash register.
If the final price of
the jeans was $22.40,
what additional discount was applied
to the marked sale price?
All right, this is interesting and useful,
cause we need to know what
we're gonna pay for our jeans.
All right, so the regular price is $40,
we're gonna assume
everything is in dollars.
It's on sale for 30 percent off.
Well if you're 30 percent off
that means it's gonna cost
70 percent of the regular price.
So let's put 70 percent of 40.
So let's multiply that times
0.7, which is the same thing
as 70 percent.
40 times 0.7, that's going to be equal to
28, $28.
Right? Yeah, seven times four is 28.
Point seven times 40
is also going to be 28.
All right, so it's going to be $28
would just be the 30% off.
But the final price of
the jeans was $22.40.
What additional discount
was applied to the marked sale price?
Well to figure that
out, we can just divide.
We can say, what fraction of 28 is 22.40.
22.40 divided by, divided by 28.
Well this is going to
be equal to, let's see,
28, and actually you could even rule out,
well I'll do the
arithmetic right over here.
So 28 goes into 22,
22.40, so get the decimal right over here.
28 doesn't go into 22,
but it does go into 224.
Let's think about it, how many times
does 28 goes into 224?
I don't know, maybe, maybe seven times?
Let's see if this works.
So it goes seven times.
Seven times eight is 56.
Seven times two is 14 plus five is 19.
And then if we were to
subtract, let's see,
we could make this a
14, regroup from here,
this would be a one, so
then we regroup from here,
this would be an 11.
14 minus six is eight,
11 minus nine is two.
Okay, so we actually could
have gotten one more in there.
So let's see, this is going to go,
28 goes into 224
exactly eight times, eight times.
Eight times eight is 64, 64.
Eight times two is 16 plus six, is 22.
No remainder.
So this is 80 percent
of the marked down price.
So if this is 80 percent,
if this is 80 percent of this,
then the additional
discount that was taken
is going to be 20 percent.
Because you take, once
you take 30 percent off,
you'd expect to pay $28,
but you only paid 80 percent of that.
So they took off another 20 percent.
They took off another 20 percent.
If you take off 20 percent,
then you're going to pay
80 percent of the price.